[Music]
fall down seven times get up eight
[Music]
even monkeys fall from trees
feed a dog for three days and it is
grateful for three years
feed a cat for three years and it
forgets after three days
[Music]
even a fool has at least one talent
10 people 10 colors
experience nature and in doing so learn
about yourself
to overcome a desperate situation
make a complete turn in one sudden burst
everyone makes mistakes nobody's perfect
[Music]
there's no accounting for taste to each
his own
[Music]
overturned water doesn't return to the
tree
a frog in a well does not know the great
sea
he who chases two rabbits catches
neither
to persevere is power
the smart hawk hides its talons
even seabream is not delicious when
eaten in loneliness
[Music]
a kite breeding a hawk
the presence of fools makes wise people
stand out
[Music]
entering a village obey the village
cannot quarrel without an opponent
the eyes are the mirror of the soul
[Music]
giving birth to a baby is easier than
worrying about it
as the cherry blossom is considered
foremost among flowers so the warrior is
foremost among men
the nail that sticks up gets hammered
down
[Music]
the week our meat that the strong eat
good medicine is bitter
[Music]
early rising benefits you three pence
even the mutterings of a man in a well
are widely known after three years
[Music]
wisdom gotten from age is better than
the shell of a tortoise
[Music]
one blind man leads the crowd
a fool always finds one still more
foolish to admire him
it is dark one inch ahead of you
[Music]
friends are known first in hardships
[Music]
if you do not enter the tiger's cave you
will not catch its cub
[Music]
with many little strokes a large tree is
filled
like father like son
sake reveals the true heart
[Music]
time flies like an arrow
the winds of tomorrow will blow tomorrow
after a storm comes the calm
when three people meet wisdom is
exchanged
cause brings results
[Music]
one man's fault is another man's lesson
[Music]
the mouth is the origin of disaster
[Music]
don't forget your original intention
[Music]
even dust when piled up can become a
mountain
[Music]
if a fish cares for the water
the water will care for the fish
[Music]
there is darkness at the foot of the
lamp
[Music]
with hardships comes pleasure
with pleasure comes hardships
[Music]
a journey of a thousand miles begins
with a single step
[Music]
good fortune and happiness will come
into the house of those who smile
[Music]
the child of a frog is a frog
don't let your daughter-in-law eat your
autumn eggplants
[Music]
if you make a mistake don't hesitate to
correct it
[Music]
it is the same life whether we spend it
crying or laughing
[Music]
polka bush a snake comes out
with the first glass a man drinks wine
with the second glass the wine drinks
the wine
with the third glass the wine drinks the
man
[Music]
the neighbor's lawn is always greener
even the head of a sardine can become
holy with devotion
he who prefers a gift of dumplings over
a gift of flowers puts needs over once
drunken life dreamy death
work of self obtainment of self
until an idiot dies he won't be cured
meeting is the beginning of partying
[Music]
charming women who have a smile for
everybody are cold-hearted
watch others behavior and correct your
own
[Music]
dirty money doesn't stay with a person
for
long there is strength in weakness
[Music]
one's act one's profit
[Music]
evil cause evil effect
[Music]
after the rain the earth hardens
[Music]
the duller the child the dearer it is
a wise man does not lose his way
a brave man does not fear
[Music]
repentance never comes first
[Music]
the eyes speak as much as the mouth
[Music]
if on reason comes reason goes
[Music]
let what has passed flow downstream
a bad wife spells a hundred years of bad
harvest
[Music]
hmm